um i want to
talk today about these summer programs
that are coming up
and these include three training
programs and what we call a research
fellowship and the research fellowship
is really a program designed to help
students and faculty design and complete
independent research projects within the
scope of three months or this upcoming
summer
so the three programs that we're going
to have
are
machine learning or biomedical data
analysis in r and python we'll talk
about how to load data analyze data
visualize data coding and r and python
you'll have some exercises and the
objective would be to design and develop
a
sample project that demonstrates your
skill two additional programs are going
to be on
infectious diseases and chronic diseases
so the infectious diseases will utilize
project examples coming from the current
pandemic
the previous pandemic or epidemic with
ebola virus tuberculosis so different
types of pathogens bacterial and viral
the program focused on chronic diseases
will use
examples from cancer
alzheimer's disease and other conditions
but will be focused on transcriptomic
data analysis including balkan rna and
single cell rna-seq
in general all of these programs are a
part of our basic curriculum and this
curriculum is available for anyone who's
here as a faculty member you can learn
more about the different topics that are
covered using project examples and i
will demonstrate in a few moments on how
these different specialization tracks
are created and they include oncology
infectious diseases neuroscience and
agriculture or biotechnology
now because we deal with a diverse
population of students they come from
different backgrounds including
engineering and life sciences we have
designed several different approaches to
teaching and mastering bioinformatics
and that includes both coding and
non-coding bioinformatics paths where we
connect the dots between biology data
and data science and the way that we do
this is by utilizing several different
resources the first resource that i want
to talk about with you today is the
omixlogic portal so the onyx logic
portal is going to be essential to what
we do
we will utilize it to make sure that
everyone has access to practice
materials
can really evaluate their learning by
completing quizzes and it's a way for us
to offer certification for those that
complete a certain number of assignments
anyone that would like to join the
programs that we're going to be offering
this summer has to have a profile on
this portal so if you could please go to
the link learn that onyxlogic.com i just
posted the link in the chat box also for
those of you that would like to follow
on this portal
i will switch over to my
my browser so on this portal anyone can
register for free
and the way to do that is first of all
to go to the login screen you can create
an account put in your name email and
password i of course have a password
already and have an account so i'm going
to sign in
now once you are signed in you will see
that on top you will see
welcome back and then your email address
what's important to do is to complete
your profile so for those of you that
are affiliated with a national
association of idea principle
investigators
university lab organization
you have to mention your
[Music]
university
maybe a lab or something like that for
those of you that are from the louisiana
biomedical research network you can
mention lbrn there
so all of this will help us in
completing the registrations we'll talk
more about the registration process
later but anyone who will join these
programs will have to have an account
that's our way of tracking
the activity and making sure that we
know
who is coming from which university
or organization
so
this portal will have access to
different types of resources and i'll go
over them in detail
what's important is that it will also
help you track progress and demonstrate
your abilities and skills as you
complete different assignments so there
you will see
your bio
the point system we talked already about
the different types of subscriptions and
all of this is going to be included and
covered by different entities that
are going to be different for different
students
but basically this is an important
section of the portal where you will
find everything that you need to do and
importantly after completing a certain
number of steps you will be offered a
certificate of completion
now beyond the profile there is going to
be just a general collection of courses
projects and examples and the way to
access that is by clicking on the menu
on the course tab you can search for
specific topics like cancer or gene
expression or something like that but
you also have a number of collections or
topics that are covered in many
different courses including project data
science genomics bioml or r so you can
just click on one of these and you will
see a collection there are also
dedicated collections at the bottom that
are organized by data type and whether
you are just getting started or would
like to explore different projects that
we have
so for anyone that has no background
bioinformatics
and this is not related specifically to
any program that we're going to be
discussing today you can simply get
started by clicking on the getting
started button
there you will find just a few resources
that are free for everyone forever that
you can go through the basic terminology
used in bioinformatics and learn about
the applications of bioinformatics what
do you use bioinformatics for so this is
something that you're welcome to share
with any connections that you have
students that are starting to learn
bioinformatics really just a resource
for anyone to get into this
topic
now we also have uh programs again under
your profile you will find several
different sections your activity courses
that we're taking and then programs and
this is really where we will assign you
to the program of your choice so
originally when you received an email
you were offered a few different options
and
when you select
one of those programs you can
essentially be added to a program that
has a schedule has a sequence of events
every event will come with a live
session or a recorded session that you
will have access to and assignments that
are specifically designed around the
topic of that particular session
for each one of these activities you
will get points and the points are for
completing courses running a pipeline or
running a code block updating your
profile or participating in a group
activity all of these points ultimately
accumulate under your profile and we
have a system for generating those
certificates based on the number of
points that you receive
for those of you that are interested to
pursue an independent project we also
have the option to use those points to
then develop an independent project
using again a system on this portal that
i will demonstrate towards the end
now
in every one of these
courses that you
find there will be project
examples and the project examples vary
by topic so here for example you can see
a collection of projects related to the
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program which is focused on different
types of pathogen viral or
parasite or bacteria and such
now we launched this program for the
first time
in january for the national association
of idea principal investigators we
offered several different courses and
we're excited to see the progress that
some of the prominent members were able
to achieve and the reason we are showing
this slide is because you can really see
the diverse uh kind of background of
participants in these programs ranging
from
people that are maybe research
assistants in labs
clinicians associate professors students
phd students graduate students and
undergraduate students as well so really
we hope that this resource and the
programs that are offered are going to
be adapted to the different levels and
needs or objectives of everyone in this
meeting today
so let me now talk specifically about
the summer programs what each program is
going to include
what are the levels the time commitments
what are the opportunities to complete
the program what will be the result of
each program and things like that and as
i'm going through
this information please feel free to
share any questions that you have in the
chat
and at the end i would be happy to
address those questions specifically i
already know that some people are
wondering about the process to actually
confirm your registration we will talk
about that uh we know that some people
have
questions about how many people can
participate from which specific
universities um so the reason why we
will do this at the end is because this
is a little bit different for the
different groups for those from the
louisiana biomedical research network
from lsu
veterinary school or other departments
at lsu
and also for people in institutions
affiliated with the national association
of idea principal investigators
so
we will have
four program choices
you can only select one but for every
one of them you can also add a basic
subscription that will get you
introduced to the different topics and
the basic terminology so these include
machine learning or biomedical data
analysis in rn python
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
transcriptomics for chronic diseases and
a program called research fellowship
so the these two programs are
intermediate level
again the beginner level if you're a
complete beginner you're welcome to
choose getting started with
bioinformatics for absolute beginners
after you complete that you should be
ready for any one of these intermediate
programs
transcriptomics for chronic diseases is
mentioned here as advanced and the
reason for that is because we will be
going through both bulk and single cell
rna-seq it will require some background
in coding and it will require an
extensive understanding of the biology
of transcription because we'll try to
look in depth at the different types of
pipelines and analysis methods that can
explain uh what is going on at that
transcription level
so that is why this program is going to
be advanced it's going to be a lot more
material and it's going to come with an
expectation that you already know a lot
of the background we're not going to go
over the basics
in terms of the bioinformatics research
fellowship program
it is mentioned here that it is for all
levels and the reason is because several
different scenarios are possible so the
first one might include just doing
literature review on a specific data set
or a specific collection of
articles uh research articles
you can also perform a simple research
project where you just take a single
data set and you kind of use standard
methods to analyze that data set and
present your results or you can have an
advanced project and that advanced
project might require multiple types of
data or several different large data
sets and maybe complex methods that will
require some time to process and
complete and then a poster presentation
or potentially even a draft for a
publication so we've seen a number of
students and faculty that have completed
in the course of three months a full
project and have resulted with a
publication even though that obviously
cannot be guaranteed it takes a lot of
effort and a long time to do that
so how are we going to support all of
these different types of programs and
what are the resources that you will
have access to once these programs start
uh by the way i forgot to mention that
for those of you that are from lsu
and from
lbrn
we do have a specific registration
process
for the louisiana biomedical research
network
it's a different process for lsu
students it is different and for nepy
members it is also different so before
we go on uh farhanna would you like to
say a few words about the registration
process for lbr and lsu
yes
hi um everyone my name is farhan
amusarat i'm the program coordinator for
the summer virtual training
program
and
let me share my screen
although most of the things are already
explained very well
by elia and zaps
okay so
yeah so i am the program coordinator for
this course and i'm also a postdoctoral
researcher at lsu school of veterinary
medicine
so um as it is already mentioned that
this course is actually open to all so
everybody can
take these courses in summer
however we offer a free registration for
at a limited number of people for lbrn
members
and lsu
school of veterinary medicine members
and navy
however
if you are a part of the lsu like lsu
main campuses if you are part of the
lsu main campus is like if your faculty
or students you can also take these
courses but you have to
pay for these courses and it has to be
through your department so
if you are interested
please um email me and we can arrange um
and check like whether it's possible or
not
and
for other people from lsu svm navy or
lbrn it is uh it is gonna be free and
the registration process after you
all uh
register through this link as you
already saw in the flyer when you open
an account and
register through this link we will have
your email address and um
names and informations and we will
contact you and detailed pro like
procedure will be explained like how to
register for the
for specific courses that you are
interested
so i guess
this is
uh
this is it
and if there's any other questions
regarding the
registration process or the courses you
can email me
my email address is already in the flyer
and i will also write in the chat
section here
all right thank you for hannah and yes i
already put your email address in the
chat box there okay thank you
okay so again um we can connect further
if you have any questions about
registration
but now let's talk a little bit about
the resources that you will have access
to and how exactly this is actually
going to work
so first of all the programs are
different from courses because they
include interactive sessions
they include assignments that are linked
to the specific topics of the program
and you will have access to big data
processing capabilities so if you
actually have a data set that you would
like to analyze you will have the
opportunity to do so and we'll go
through a number of different resources
in different programs that are more
appropriately designed to address those
kinds of data sets or data types and
those kinds of uh projects
so
first of all
again i want to uh kind of talk a little
bit about the fact that this is intended
to make bioinformatics more accessible
to anyone and so anyone that you think
might not be a good fit for the program
they don't really know anything or
something like that we do recommend
trying out to sign up and there are two
specific courses there's a course for
introduction to bioinformatics and a
course called bytes and molecules and
both of these courses are designed
specifically for those that either have
not touched bioinformatics in a long
time or would like to just get started
and that's free and accessible for
anyone around the world so you're
welcome to just go ahead and do that and
specifically this is designed because
there is a need in bioinformatics
training and skills for anyone who's
involved in biomedical research
now for those of you that are going to
be joining the actual programs the
programs are going to include access to
the training materials you will have
access to data analysis tools curated
project data sets and interactive
sessions with a variety of faculty
members and i just want to mention that
you will also have access to a library
of pre-recorded lectures that are
contributed by different members of the
programs that are represented here as
well so in in the past we've had a
number of guest lectures from the
louisiana biomedical research network
from companies from research institutes
from
the administration of the different
programs and really
getting access to all of these in the
context of a specific program is going
to be
kind of opening up further opportunities
for you to learn and explore specific
opportunities to complete a program or
even continue your education beyond what
we can offer online
now an important resource that we are
going to be using throughout the program
is a user-friendly interface that allows
us to build large data processing
pipelines interactively without any
coding where you will have access to
five terabytes of storage cloud
containers that you can deploy to
perform complex analyses and technical
support so if something doesn't work you
have someone to talk to
this uh platform is embedded in the
educational resources that we will go
through because it combines the logic of
analysis by using color-coded uh
interfaces by offering an explanation
about each method with links where you
can explore them with a variety of
output and input formats that you can
kind of intuitively understand and we
will go through these examples so that
you can appreciate first of all
the diverse nature of data using
different types of sequencing techniques
and the diverse nature of projects and
obviously every project requires some
preparation some processing and to skip
that part just to conceptually
understand and appreciate it we have
this resource
after the program is complete or during
the program itself
you will be able to utilize uh the
platform itself to perform your analysis
so all of the different sections that we
will go through will actually have
working resources that you can use
now in addition to that we're going to
go from context to logic practice and
then to independence and as a result
many of the analyses that you will
perform you will be able to take away
together with you as an interactive
notebook that notebook will contain code
will contain access to the data and
visual output so you will actually be
able to hopefully uh go from a very
basic introduction to what
bioinformatics is all about to
practically using bioinformatics without
any technical uh necessary steps and
then eventually being able to
interrogate that data in a way that you
can both understand and share
so let's first talk about the biomedical
data analysis using r and python
so here obviously one of the challenges
is to leverage
both of these languages to understand
how they can be used to perform the same
thing and typically when we say
bioinformatics using r and python we
talk about producing plots performing
statistical analysis and an introduction
to machine learning so the way that this
was going to work on the portal i'm just
going to switch really quickly
is
by um doing the following so again if
you have already created an account on
the portal
we can
take a look at one example so if you
type in introduction to
you will see that there's going to be an
introduction to python an introduction
to r
so i'm just going to demonstrate very
quickly what that looks like
in each one of the courses you will have
some lessons that are available for free
and those are the ones without the star
and then the ones without with a star
are only accessible through a
subscription now that subscription is
what essentially will come with the
program so you will have access to all
of the basic as well as the premium
materials
here we can look at one example that
should be accessible to anyone
where there's an introduction to
plotting
and you will see that each section will
include an overview of the syntax so
that you can understand how code is
written
with the ability to actually
understand the results so you can see
that
these results
are representative of what you should
get as a result of running code and then
you will also be able to practice this
code right in the
in this section as well so for example
just simply running this code is
impossible i have to understand what is
being done
and
once i do this
i will be able to run and complete the
assignment and as you progress it will
become more and more complete and more
and more complex
and so once you have completed all of
these assignments and you're able to
understand how to load data visualize
data
and do exploratory analysis and so forth
so
this program in parallel will offer
examples in r and python you can choose
either one you don't have to just try to
accomplish both of them
at the end as these courses become more
complex you will also have access to
interactive notebooks where you can run
a full code and submit that to
somebody who can review and guide you if
you have any questions or any challenges
and actually becoming independent with
those methods of analysis
the reason we are focused on r and
python are for two reasons the first is
that this is the most demanded skills in
the industry but also because a lot of
publications leverage visual visual
outputs
from
packages that are commonly used in both
of these languages
so it will start with an introduction to
both r and python and then you will also
get an introduction to data science and
r and introduction to data science and
python which covers a variety of topics
like data wrangling machine learning and
statistics unsupervised and supervised
types of analysis and other types of
methods that are listed here in detail
now this starts from very basic things
like being able to load data understand
matrices
being able to call on specific rows and
columns then it will go through more
complex analyses and the way that this
is done is
structured in the same way that was
already explained from understanding the
problem to then being able to learn the
code modify outputs settings and then
finally apply to a specific data set
now in all of these methods you will
find a coding challenge an interactive
notebook and assignments and these
assignments again could be reviewed by
the guide of the program so that you
actually can overcome any technical
challenges that you will face
now importantly many of the principles
of exploratory analysis are specific to
a different type of data and we will try
to incorporate examples that show how
data analysis using traditional methods
for
exploratory analysis and more advanced
and more adopted more recently
have been changing as a result of the
changing nature of the type of data and
the quantity of data that is being
produced we will talk about how to
evaluate different methods and we will
also think about when to apply different
types of methods to what kind of
challenge knowing that we can oftentimes
be
looking at
different stages of the analysis that
actually combine all of these methods
together in a single workflow now at the
end of kind of an overview of different
methodologies and use cases you will be
introduced to projects and those
projects will include examples from
diagnostics and cancer biology to single
cell and tissue composition and projects
like microbiome and infection
so again if you have any questions about
this first program this is an
intermediate level program so you need
to know a little bit definitely don't be
intimidated by the program anyone will
be able to successfully complete all of
the assignments
and always if you have any trouble
someone from our team will be able to
assist you with that
now the second program that i want to
talk about is transcriptomics for
chronic diseases
the program is designed to address
commonly used methods
for data preparation which is a pipeline
to process fast q files and turn them
into a table of expression for gene or
isoform expression
announce statistical analysis of
differences between groups of samples
like t-test or eventually adapted into
packages like dec pec2 hr and others
where you will be able to perform the
analysis
explain it in a biological way and also
produce the different types of plots
that are commonly used in publications
now we will also focus on single cell
here as well and that is why we call
this program more advanced program
because it will try to kind of cover
everything that is today used for
transatomic data analysis and single
cell comes with a whole range of
complications that are different from
bulk rna-seq and learning everything in
a single program will require a little
bit more effort
now the reason why we study
transcriptomics is of course because
it's a good proxy for translation for
the proteins that are being produced
specifically in the program we will talk
about next generation sequencing as
opposed to some of the other types of
methods of quantification of rna and so
we will skip microarray and kind of
western blots and things like that and
we'll focus specifically on next
generation sequencing and we will see
examples of projects that apply
these techniques to a number of
different directions including
biomedical research topics like
diagnostics and therapeutics in the era
of precision medicine especially focused
on examples from cancer biology and
bio medical studies in that domain
the topics will give you both an
overview of the different resources for
transcriptomic data analysis and all the
way to some hands-on examples that will
be curated and designed to illustrate a
specific
understanding or a specific topic
now for those of you that are not
interested in necessarily becoming
proficient at coding
it is also going to be enough to just
understand the logic of the analysis and
we will utilize the tbi info platform to
make sure that the logic is clear
because it provides a number of
resources that will also
guide you as you try to apply these
techniques to a data set of your own
you will also have access to interactive
plots that you can explore
and downstream interpretation including
pathway analysis gene set enrichment
analysis gene ontologies and others
as well as interactive outputs for
exploring the
types of mapping techniques that we're
going to utilize
and also exploratory analysis methods
in the era of bulk rna-seq becoming more
accessible the prominence of machine
learning has
increased and so a lot of people
leverage big data sets like the cancer
genome atlas
and others to explore associations that
are more complex than what you know
typically could be done with
differential gene expression or linear
regression and so we will look at a
number of machine learning methods
specifically applicable to continuous
data used in rna-seq and there we will
look at decision trees
different types of discriminant analysis
and classification methods like random
forest
now when we transition to single cell
transcriptomics we will discuss the
common methods of data preparation as
well as common methods used for analysis
of single cell rna-seq including
dimensionality reduction umap t-sne and
others and pseudotime trajectories so
that we understand both technically how
those should be performed but also in
terms of biological interpretability how
do we actually use some of these methods
to get the types of plots and results
that typically are presented in research
articles
as i mentioned all of the programs will
be supplemented by project examples
these include analysis of
different types of
projects and these projects are going to
range from cancer to infectious diseases
and that brings me to our next program
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
which is going to cover um some overlap
of topics it will include transcriptomic
data as well but it will focus
specifically on the way bioinformatics
is used to study uh the actual pathogen
as well as host pathogen interaction and
so that is why we'll talk about analysis
first of all of genomic data
and also analysis of the host pathogen
interaction uh in genomic and
transcriptomic data so we'll talk about
topics like sequence variation and
alignments evolutionary and phylogenetic
analysis functionality and protein
structure how do we map variants onto
the protein
structure excuse me
how do we analyze 3d structures of
proteins and then transcriptomic
analysis of host response so to do that
we kind of first have to start maybe by
talking about what is the difference
between chronic diseases and infectious
diseases
and
the main difference of course is that
infectious diseases are caused directly
by a pathogen and they spread and the
chronic diseases are caused by
environmental and lifestyle choices and
they typically do not spread and so
because of that we will take examples
that will help us understand how these
pathogens are different
and and how do they actually cause what
we cause what we call disease
and what are the specific functions that
we would like to understand
now the study of
pathogens of course is one of the first
interests in microbiology but also
it is a first example of bioinformatics
leveraged to actually in almost real
time
analyze and understand the evo evolution
of the pathogen as it spreads in a
population so the first example of a
very successful utilization of
bioinformatics in the context of an
epidemic was in the 2014
ebola outbreak even though
bioinformatics obviously has been used
before but during that time in a very
short period of time researchers were
able to
track the evolution as well as design
interventions that are both population
level and
personalized
vaccines and antivirals that became
successful and are now being used to
kind of address these outbreaks so we're
going to use that example as one of the
starting examples of how we can use
bioinformatics effectively to do that
but beyond that we will obviously use
the current pandemic as one of the
examples that is still ongoing
we'll talk about how in this pandemic
specifically
different types of methods have been
used to understand
the interaction between the host and the
pathogen how does the pathogen enter the
cell where can we find the specific
mutations responsible for adaptation how
can we identify protein targets how can
we think about the intervention and
think about the relationships between
the different strains of pathogens
now to do that we will try to understand
different types of sequencing techniques
that have been utilized in the different
examples that i just mentioned
and obviously the specific needs for the
analysis that we will discuss and we
will talk about how these different
types of data are used where where to
find them where can we find collections
of data about these different types of
diseases and what are some both open
source and kind of
available online tools that people use
and what are some of the methods that
are more custom and how to ask questions
from these types of data sets
so bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
will include
kind of a range of topics and a range of
different types of data
so that you can access all of these
different tools
the final program that i want to talk
about is called the research fellowship
the research fellowship is a different
type of a program it does not have a set
curriculum because really the objective
of this program is to provide training
in the context of developing an
independent research project
so to develop an independent research
project your objective is to actually
design a research poster or a project
that you could present to others and so
with that objective in mind what we will
do is we will have access to big data
mentorship and training
and that will be divided up into several
different topics or domains and so these
domains include precision medicine like
cancer neuroscience and others
population health like infectious
diseases biotechnology and agriculture
or even space and astrobiology so
the way that you can design and complete
a project during the short period of
time is by following pre-design steps
on the process of identifying a question
finding a data set that you could ask
that question from
knowing how to analyze the data to
produce the results that you need and
then presentation or how do you
summarize your findings in such a way
that people understand how you arrived
at those conclusions and what are the
actual research findings that you're
presenting
so it all starts with
literature review many of you probably
already know how to do a literature
review but in the context of
bioinformatics literature review
involves several additional steps first
of all we do want to find existing
resources that could be categorized in
databases maybe pipelines or
examples of methods and how they were
applied
in many cases you're looking for gaps
controversy and debate and so a lot of
people in the domain of bioinformatics
compare and contrast different pipelines
maybe evaluate the
comprehensiveness of a resource or a
database and in many cases you can then
uh identify a question or hypothesis
specifically structured around the area
of your interest or your expertise
and then our program will involve
several different steps
including an introduction which will
give you an overview of different types
of methods and tools that you can use
evaluation so that you can propose a
project and get feedback on that
proposal and then practice so that
whenever you are ready to perform the
analysis you're actually understanding
and you're equipped to be able to do
that independently so the outcome of
that is to complete a project and submit
it on our portal and to get there you
will have access to mentorship
someone to review your proposal
technical support from our team and a
community of like-minded students that
you can interact with and potentially
design even group projects together with
them
so on the portal you will be able to
utilize our system to guide you through
all of the steps that are typically
included in preparing a poster
presentation and here i have a brief
recording of how this is possible to do
on the portal itself so the first step
would be to complete your profile
then you would have to add your bio and
connect to your org id or your social
media
and after you do that you will have to
earn 10 000 points by practicing
different types of analyses that we
describe in programs and courses and
complete a course
that speaks about the way that you can
utilize bioinformatics to do a research
project
now after that you can start your own
project
and the project will have several
different sections including an overview
kind of reproducible projects include a
reference data set that is curated and
prepared
so we will go through the process of
submitting that data set on dataverse
and explaining the metadata
we will then talk about all the standard
sections like abstract introduction
methods results discussion and
conclusion including a list of
references and acknowledgments at the
end
now as a result of completing such a
project you will be able to add that
project to your resume or present it at
a poster conference
and so here we have several examples of
people that have submitted either as a
preprint
others have published in the
undergraduate
journals
and others have even used
some of the results that they were
working on in their ongoing research
studies
some just use that example to
train
and acquire skills as well
but what's important is that at the end
of the summer
in august we will have our virtual omics
research symposium
this symposium is a bi-annual event that
we organize together with our partners
where we invite experts from
bioinformatics research
in industry and academia as well as
experts in bioinformatics education to
discuss pressing topics and advances in
bioinformatics but also we provide a
platform for students faculty and
researchers to present those posters and
get feedback specific feedback on their
projects and how to take those projects
further so it's really an opportunity to
find mentors and communities that you
can join and learn about how to
implement these this kind of training um
wherever you are
so again with that i am happy to take
any questions that you might have
i will briefly mention the process of uh
again registration
so for any one of you
that is coming from nepy from the
national association of idea principal
investigators
one of your questions might be
well how do i know that i am from nepea
right how do i know that i am affiliated
with the nappy institution the way to
know that is to go to
nepi.org
which is the website that lists out
all of the institutions
and all of the states
that participate in this program
so if just scroll down a little bit you
will see this map
on the map if you click on any one of
these you will find
a description
and if you scroll down beyond that you
will also see all of the active
principal investigators
so to participate in the program from
nepy
you have to be a member of the
institution where the pi is at
right so if your
lab pi
is a member of nepe that's great
if in your institution there is api that
is enough right so really this is just
the institution so for example in
louisiana
people from lsu
lsu hsc
et cetera now we only have a limited
number of nepy licenses that are going
to be covered a hundred percent
and that's 50.
and then we have an additional 100 that
are going to be offered at 75 off so
that's still a significant discount and
so i
i think it would be useful if you also
don't know
whether your institution is a part of
nepi you can simply search
for that institution
um
yeah so so for example
oh this is rhode island
i think the way you search is by going
one second i think you have to go to
the state first so
i'm actually i'm not so familiar with
names of universities in every state but
in any case you should be able to find
yeah and you can also go here by region
and you can see
the different actual
projects that are funded by
by the idea program but by the nih idea
program and nepi just brings together
all of the pis from those funded
projects
so again this is for netbean
how do you register if you are a part of
nippy so all you need to do is you need
to create the account on
learn.nxlogic.com
once you have created an account when
you are making that account it will ask
you what institution you're from and you
will have to add into your bio that
you're a part of nappy lbrn or lsu
or any one of these institutions so
please do that
and let us know so we have here
japs who is going to be able to assist
you if you are from nepi or from any
other university for that matter
for hana again can be helpful for those
that are from lsu lsu svn or from
lbirn
and we also have a specific process
for those of you that are for from lbrn
uh so from lbrm you do not directly go
to us
you actually go to this page and uh john
here from lbrn has already shared this
link
so the link i'm going to post it again
lists out
all of the different programs that we
just discussed and then has here at the
bottom of the page the registration link
so if you are from lbrn you click there
and you just process from there and what
will happen is once you submit that
application you will be reviewed and if
it is granted then you will be informed
about that decision
through lbrn itself not through pine so
you will have an email from
someone within lbrn that will notify you
about you being accepted and i believe
that the last day of registration is may
27th even though that might be extended
into the first week of june
john and farhana
correct me if i'm wrong here
making sure
um
yeah john i don't know if you want to i
was trying to unmute and you
yeah yes that's correct you are correct
about that
um i've been getting a lot of
non elbowing participants trying to
apply on our form so
i'm having to decline those
unfortunately and i'm relaying that
information but please uh
people when you look at the form it does
very clearly state which institutions
you can apply from and they have to be
from louisiana thank you
all right perfect so thank you
now um for those of you that are not
from any of these institutions so if you
are not from
lb iran you are not from lsu you are not
from a nepea associate institution
you can still apply for these programs
the way you do this is you let us know
so the best way would be to email hello
at pine.bio
and that is the email address for jabs
she will be able to identify which
program is the best for you have a
conversation with you if needed and then
recommend the best pass so there are
several different pricing points from
beginners to advanced with different
kind of levels of access that you can
get for different lengths
for those of you that are interested in
a program not just over the summer
yes those are available as well
again you can go simply to the program
tab
and on the program tab you will see
different types of programs and
different dates and and things like that
and you can explore those uh you are
also welcome to email us about them if
you have a specific program in mind that
you are interested in in a specific time
frame
in a specific location we run these at
different time zones with different
types of trainers and so we should be
able to help you with that as well
so hopefully anna that answers your
question
so as you saw today
we cover many different topics in
bioinformatics i want to make a final
note to those of you that are faculty
if you are a faculty at any of these
institutions and you would like to
include any of these resources in your
training and your coursework throughout
the fall
and into the year you're welcome to
utilize these resources as well we have
uh guides and and all kinds of resources
to support that
you're welcome to reach out to me
directly if you are a faculty member or
you are interested in that and we can
discuss the options for that as well
if you would like to kind of
introduce your own material and you
would like to
share that material with the national
association of idea principal
investigators i also want to mention as
that
one of the objectives of the national
association of idea principal
investigators is to coordinate sharing
of resources related to bioinformatics
and so if you go on the nepi website
under resources
and there's a tab here training
resources
our onyx logic programs are listed here
as well as some of the other resources
that are shared by
the members of this community and you
can even submit your own resource here
at the bottom as well
so if you are teaching bioinformatics or
you have a summer program or you have a
program that
others can leverage for free or paid
this is a place to submit that program
and
make sure that the community knows about
it so
please do that and if you have any
questions about that you can simply go
to this page
all right so thank you everyone again
for joining today
excited to get this program off the
ground soon
we only have a few days until the
official registration date is going to
be closing and then after that we will
have some room to kind of accept those
that are still
not sure
but please do share this with your
network and we will post this video on
youtube as well so you can share that
you will receive an email from us with
that recording and thank you again for
joining today we look forward to
interacting with you as the programs
begin
you